I want to let our viewers and listeners
know that if you were listening to the
show on one of our radio affiliates
Casey HW in chewelah Washington it will
no longer be available because the
station does not want to lose sponsors i
received the unfortunate news yesterday
here is an email i received David I've
gotten a few complaints out of our
seventy percent Republican community and
I'm going to pull the show I agree with
most everything you say but can't lose
sponsors sorry can I blame them these
stations do need to make financial
decisions someone clearly called them
and said hey we are going to pull
sponsorship of your radio station if you
keep broadcasting the david packard show
and it's disturbing because as we all
know commercial talk radio is mostly
right-wing we're talking about an
independent station here in kc HW a
non-commercial station and they still
need to pull the show because the
right-wingers don't lat like our views
we have the wrong opinions for the
sponsors on Casey HW yeah I'm surprised
you're not willing to change your
positions at all to I know what they
want to hear I should have written back
Rachel and said oh on which positions
should I say something different yeah I
mean I thought you're just got going to
kind of change the whole narrative of
the show and make it at basically a
aligned with what they want you to say
sure and if you want to get in touch
with them and tell them that they should
put the david pakman show back on the
air you can do so using the contact form
at kch w.org or by calling 509 935 6627
interesting little anecdote the most
unusual email i got about why the show
was being pulled from a station was a
station in i believe it was Missouri or
Missouri as some say because I referred
to the communion wafer in Catholic
churches as a cookie and that led Pat
this was before your time and Rachel's
as well that led to the show being
pulled that's still the most unusual
show polling story that we've spent
experience that's unacceptable I can't
believe you did that also wildly
specific to it was super
yeah so this is bad uh and this is only
going to get worse if Donald Trump is
President Supreme Court justices we also
already know about media consolidation
trumpets promised lawsuits against media
outlets where they say things he doesn't
like so uh this does relate to the
upcoming election